wie konnte das passieren wie kann es
sein dass ein sexualstraftäter der zehn
jahre in einer psycho anstalt sei es
sich einfach so ein opfer sucht 14 jahre
alt schützen wir unsere kinder genug
nein das findet karsten stein ein mann
der offenen worte der ehrlichen weise
ein mann der sich den kinderschutz zur
lebensaufgabe gemacht hat und den ich
jetzt ganz herzlich hier bei uns im
studio begrüßen möchte guten tag hallo
schönberg das geht ins herz als sie von
dem fall r liegen vor dem tod dieses 14
jahre alten mädchens gehört haben wie
viele kinder noch wie viele kinder noch
ist sie endlich verstehen dass es so
nicht weitergehen darf in unserem land
schützen wir täter mehr als kinder und
die gesellschaft wie viele kinder müssen
noch sterben missbraucht werden
vergewaltigt werden geht ja nicht nur um
kinder soll warum frauen bis wir endlich
verstehen dass es so nicht weitergehen
darf für mich hat kinderschutz oberste
priorität ist auch unverhandelbar dass
hier viel versagt wurde dass dieser
junge mit sicherheit schon als kind aus
schlimme erfahrung gemacht hat ist das
eine er kommt frei er wird überwacht und
wie seit überwachung zum schluss aus
dass einmal im monat jemand vorbeikam
wie beim bewährungshelfer wie konnte so
etwas passieren
niemand wird als täter geboren mehr
werden so gemacht das weiß ich aus
eigener erfahrung aber hier hat wieder
komplett das system versagt und wieder
ist ein kind tut und was wird daraus
geschehen was wird sich verändern nichts
wenn wir nicht endlich aufschreien und
sagen es reicht wo ist die politik wo es
die justiz
die zahlen zeigen ist konstante zahlen
von 2005 bis 2020 15 jahre dutzend
fahrer hunderttausend fahrer
kindesmissbrauch tausende von opfern und
die 160 180 tausend opfer von missbrauch
und die täter wird bekommen die den
meisten 80 prozent von den zwei jahre
freiheitsstrafe für uns da von 90 auf
bewährung bewährung hat das mit
neustrelitz im endeffekt die gleiche
geschichte wie der junge schon vorweg
hat in neustrelitz bekommt der täter
sofort keine haftstrafe und war 15 was
muss noch passieren
meine tochter ist elf jahre alt wie
wollte mein kind schützen muss ich es
selbst schützen und dann kann nicht sein
und deswegen fordere ich hier von der
politik sich nicht nur darum zu kümmern
in europa die europa polizei zu spielen
sondern vor allen dingen anzufangen
unsere bürger unsere kinder auch zu
schützen wir helfen überall und das
machen wir ja aber datiert ist wie immer
versagen und das wird dann wieder ab
deklariert als bedauerliche einzelfälle
sind endlich jetzt sind so viele kinder
die noch leben könnten weil die
gesellschaft versagt und weg sieht und
weil die politik versagt und wechseln
und die justiz ja mehr täter toleriert
als kinder schützt ist die wahrheit was
hätten sie sich für diesen mann über den
wir jetzt so viel erfahren mittlerweile
was hätten sie sich für den gewünscht
wer hat seine erste tat in ganz jungen
jahren begangen als er selber 14 war da
hat er die erste vergewaltigung den
ersten missbrauch versucht war dann zehn
jahre in der psychiatrie was hätten sie
sich für diesen mann für diesen jungen
gewünscht wie werden sie mit ihm
umgegangen also erstmal ist es so wir
haben viele menschen die eine einfach
den falschen weg gehen ich will das
jetzt nicht abtun aber entscheidend ist
wo sind zum beispiel auch die
präventionsprogramme es gibt schon
prävention nicht zum täter werden auch
da es gibt nur ganz wenige anlaufstellen
ja wir haben so viele pädophil
veranlagte menschen in unserem land auch
kinderschänder hier immer wieder zum
thema werden 80 über 80% rückfallquote
wir haben so wenig anders stellt wie
sollen die sich stellen auch selber
schützen nicht zum täter werden und dann
werden sie auch noch toleriert ich hatte
mir für den jungen wünscht dass er
abgefangen worden ich hätte mir für den
jungs schon gewünscht dass er damals als
er so geworden ist werden ist mit 14
dass man ihnen in der familie betreut
hat sind auch raus genommen hätte da
erst gar nicht so geworden ist der junge
ist doch nicht als mörder geboren er
habe ihn so gemacht mich hat man auch so
gemacht vom opfer zum täter mich hat man
so gemacht ich hab die kurve irgendwann
gekriegt aber ich war 18 jahren
kriminell so lange hat es gedauert ihr
kennt ja viele dinge gar nicht erlebt
ich hätte nicht gern erlebt dass meine
freundin vergewaltigt wird und und
hinfällig hätten viele dinge richtig an
aber das hier tolerieren ich nicht ich
habe null akzeptanz bei vergewaltigung
und missbrauch und 0 ups zu einer
politik die sich um alles kümmert aber
nicht über ihre eigenen bürger und vor
allem nicht um ihre eigene kinder sorry
ist wir merken es sie werden sie sehen
auch viele fälle und werden da sehr
emotional sprechen vielen menschen auch
aus dem herzen die diesen fall sehen und
sich fragen wer hat er versagt was
hätten die behörden tun können warum
weiß man nicht was dieser mann im
internet macht warum kann er sich
einfach so mit einem jungen mädchen
verabreden warum klingelt da vielleicht
nur einmal im monat jemand und sagt aha
da sind sie also und verabschiedet sich
wieder das ist etwas was bei ganz vielen
menschen zu völligem unverständnis für
kein geld da kein geld da keine keine
mitarbeiter da die ressourcen sind nicht
da ja nehmen die schule wir haben wir
haben 1500 schulpsychologen die zustände
sind für 10 millionen schüler bei der
anzahl von gewalttaten die da sind
unfassbar und wir haben auch kaum
mitarbeiter vom jugendamt im rausgehen
oder auch hier man muss einfach gucken
wie überlastet die auch sind ja wir
haben abgebaut der polizei stellen
abgebaut und wir fragen uns warum alles
schlimmer wird natürlich wenn ja wenn
wir nur mal alles weniger fahren und
nicht hochfahren weil die probleme sind
mehr geworden wir haben das
digitalisiert auch die einflüsse auch
das sage ich immer wieder den eltern
bitte lasst eure kinder nicht
unbeaufsichtigt irgendwelchen
online-spielen sein dass ring trieb das
sind die basis die supermärkte für die
kinderschänder die suchen dort gezielt
kinder und wenn sie dann haben dann
versuchen sie erst mit geld zu locken
dass sie im bilde hinschicken und wenn
sie dort ihr macht haben presse ist es
wissen war teilweise schon wo sie wohnen
bitte lasst uns endlich anfangen
aufzuwachen und ihn der weit ins gesicht
zu sehen in deutschland ist ein paradies
für kinderschänder und vergewaltiger und
kinderpornographie deutschland ist auch
unter den drei top ländern die nicht
ihre kinder schützen mit cannoli sein
und jetzt jeden ball rüber und die
koffer wir schaffen langsamer der
politik klarmachen dazu ist das sind
funktioniert habe gezeigt im letzten
jahr war viel gesetze im bundestag
getragen warum mit dem druck den wir
machen in der öffentlichen wahrnehmung
aber wer hat mehr öffentliche warnungen
als ihr könnte eigentlich menschen druck
machen ich will die leute sitzen haben
die verantworten deswegen werden wir
sitzen auch sie her damit der dem ganzen
eine stimme geben damit werde druck
machen damit wir hören was auch sie in
ihrer arbeit erleben die frage die sich
hier in diesem fall immer wieder stellt
ist jemand der mit 14 jahren bereits
seine erste tat begeht überhaupt in der
form wie wir uns das wünschen und sie
haben auch ihre eigene kriminelle
vergangenheit angesprochen dieser punkt
eine kurve zu kriegen wieder eingliedern
in unsere gesellschaft wie viel kraft
verwenden wir darauf und muss die kraft
der überwachung eine andere werden wir
sehen wie das fängt ja schon viel früher
an warum fangen wir nicht viel früher an
schulen den schulen in den grundschulen
in den kitas mit prävention und
aufklärung aufklärung gegen mobbing
gewalt rassismus hass auf den gegen
missbrauch dass die kinder sich
anvertrauen der müssen passiert ist zum
größten teil in den eigenen familien
wenn wir da schon versagen dann dann
bereiten wir das ja schon vor den weg
und wenn dir erstmal abrutschen so wie
ich dann fällst immer weiter und dann
bist du musst nur der bodensatz der
abschaum der gesellschaft und wir
möglichst keine hilfe mehr wir holen
viele menschen unser land weil wir
helfen wollen aber wir lassen sie sich
selbst und wundern uns dass wir dutzende
hundertfache gruppenvergewaltigung haben
bedeutet das dass deshalb menschen unter
anderem gruppen ferry weil wir sind
natürlich nicht aber wir überlassen sie
sich selbst und wurden an sich das nicht
funktionieren kann das geht nicht wir
müssen integrieren wir müssen helfen und
hilfeleistung machen der junge war 14
jahre ist komplett abgedriftet gut da
war wenigstens mal ein gutachter hat
gesagt er ist gefährlich gehabt erkannt
aber das tor nicht gefährlich geboren
den hat man die 14 jahre so gemacht und
wo war die jugendämter im vorfeld was
hat man den jungen vielleicht angetan
war klar jetzt solltet nicht reserviert
er muss jetzt mit voller härte bestraft
werden und die gesellschaft und menschen
müssen wir ihnen geschützt werden aber
wir schaffen uns unsere täter indem wir
nicht eingreifen weil wir es können und
hätte man prävention bevor menschen zu
opfern und tätern werden und da wird
versagt ich danke ihnen ganz für ihre
wut bei diesem thema bei einem fall der
uns alle so aufgewühlt hat herr stahl
finden sie worte für die menschen in
gottenheim mit der heimat von aline für
die angehörigen
ich war auf 8 beerdigungen und auf
mehreren man machen es nimmt mich jedes
mal mit bin jedes mal zu tränen gerührt
und sehr diese verzweiflung in den
menschen warum passiert das hier es
passiert überall es fehlt nur den
kleinen städten mit kleineren namen er
auf ich kann den bürger nur sagen haltet
das gedenken an aline aufrecht vergisst
sie nicht macht der mahnwache macht
gedenktage las sie unvergessen sein denn
wenn wir anfangen diese kinder zu
vergessen dann fangen wir an als
gesellschaft immer mehr abzustumpfen und
es ist doch nicht nur einer alien ich
war an so vielen beerdigungen gab so
viele kinder gesehen die weit vor ihrer
zeit gegangen sind und will dort nicht
mehr die kette heute jung der war 25
jahre alt er wurde getötet sich eine
gruppe vergewaltigung und deshalb müssen
wir daraus lernen wir können die
vergangenheit nicht ändern aber wir
müssen die zukunft ändern für unsere
kinder denn sie sind unsere zukunft die
moral einer gesellschaft zeigt sich in
dem was sie für ihre kinder tut hat
dietrich bonhoeffer angesagt also bitte
worauf warten wir die politik wird sie
nicht machen die politik hört nur auf 1
auf öffentlichen druck da tagen neun
jahren bitterer erfahrung kinderschutz
land carsten scheibe deutliche worte
starke worte worte die mit neben die ins
herz treffen danke dass sie hier in
dieser sendung zahlen danke dass du mir
die chance gibt es darüber zu reden
[Musik]